ich hab mal das kitz und herzlich
willkommen zum neuen video wir werden
heute wieder ein kombi ding machen aus
minecraft und rocket liegt das hat über
letzten mal mich sehr gut gefallen
ich werde heute in roddick eine
challenge machen und zwar für jedes
gegentor das ich bekomme werde ich mir
einen dicken fetten strich mit dem
edding den er schon aus krimis kennt auf
den kopf machen auf die stirn
also je nach typ und ich mache das first
try also ich vielleicht lasse ich sogar
drin wie ich rüber zum spiel switche
damit ihr auch garantiert sehen könnt
dass es viele da ist es schon fast reihe
ist so dann können wir nämlich einfach
gucken also wenn es kann sein dass ich
einfach ein gegner bekomme der mich
komplett weg klatsch der mich des todes
zerstört ich kassiert zehn tore
dann sieht meinen kopf aus wie ein
barcode danach aber okay dass die
challenge ich mache ja auch ihr wisst
schon
mittlerweile eigentlich dass ich wenn
ich mir so behinderte challenges stelle
ich dir ja dann auch durchziehen und ich
weiß nicht was wir jetzt dabei gedacht
habe wo ich wieder behindern gesagt das
war wieder sehr sehr sehr unüberlegt von
mir es tut mir leid
ja was wirklich hart machen genau ich
wollte heute man noch musik anmachen zum
ersten mal live musik weil ich das voll
cool finde also schon während der
aufnahme musik zu hören das finde ich
viel cooler
dann ist die ganze geschichte figur wir
dass es so eine sache die im stream so
extrem mag dass man da im hintergrund
schon die musiker hat la musica ja und
was jetzt mit den gegnern hier amigos
hws mehr da ich der einheiten
unterstrichen namen von dem sollte man
sich unbedingt fernhalten weil die leute
mit unterschiedlichen namen sind immer
richtig krass sollte sich mittlerweile
rumgesprochen haben diesen sehr sehr
gefährlich sind auch alle
sexualstraftäter ja nein was leicht zu
von essen
ich habe ich nicht was handy bimmelt
beschreibt
schnell ausmachen der twist ich leute
ihr kennt mich doch ich bin doch fakt
professionell oder von seiner media kurz
halt nicht mit ihr boxe ich mich aber
nicht mit dem anderen der anderen
matches das mag ich nicht das finde ich
überhaupt nicht so hier so eine
konstellation oder ok kann maximal zwei
falle gefressen
jetzt kriegt eine gute schwert combo die
range mac os
das ging schnell krass so den echten
nicht übertrieben viel gefressen
damit sind nur noch zwei gegner mal
gucken wo der andere ist ich habe zwei
tnt eigentlich okay 18 pfeil ist jetzt
nicht so übertrieben aber es sollte
gehen an erwischt du wo hast du dich
versteckt da da ist der haye klar die
jazz reicht es nicht
er hat halt auch noch ein eisen schwer
zu der die jetzt also muss ich schon
die switche lampen im manne was der
jetzt schon wieder gefressen hat anfang
ist unwahrscheinlich es ist
unwahrscheinlich dass er wieder in der
vitrine bekommen hat und trotzdem steht
ihr einfach immer noch da es ist eine
schande
ein herz ich glaub ich gedacht wow junge
junge um junge das ist richtig gab der
frist wieder extremst
nein das herz wieso hab ich dir nicht
erwischen mit dem schwert micro
so leute da sind wir
nein ich habe das spiel im fokus
klasse parade gebaut na klar machen wir
dort nachteil ist jetzt dass mein spiel
auch wissen mein pc dazu tendiert ein
bisschen zulegen wenn ich hier jumping
kauf nehme
obwohl ich die settings müssen runter
gekriegt hab geträumt
ja er geht er geht der geht glaube ich
der geht
nein da geht nicht ja ok ja ich will
gerade sagen was was passiert eigentlich
wenn ich gut spiele davon habe ich
eigentlich gar nichts weil die challenge
mit den gegentoren bezieht sich nur auf
die gegentore logischerweise wie das
beim gegentor changes halt so ist
eur o o holen ich habe wahrscheinlich
jetzt gerade eben den übergang zwischen
den beiden spielen drin gelassen aber
ziemlich beschleunigt so dass es nicht
langweilig wird aber so dass ihr sehen
könnt dass die runde drei ist kamera
macht er gut
okay da versuche ich einfach für mich
selbst zu gewinnen er kommt gut und der
geht rein
wunderbar übrigens ding ist hier am
start
also für den fall der fälle gibt es hier
oben aufs häubchen ein paar infizierung
ich hoffe nur dass die musik jetzt sich
allzu lautes und racing game sound aber
lieber musik zu laut und games ein
bisschen zu leise als andersrum
du machst jetzt war kein tor ein
was ist der andere rang er ist sogar
veteran alter der sogar noch an über mir
ich bin nur profi dj dafür schlage ich
mich nicht schlecht mit diesem 2 0 toren
die wir gerade kärnten und das ist
eigentlich auch ganz nett aus aber das
reicht nicht durch
und der sommer noch einer 30 läuft bei
mir alter schillig er man könnte
theoretisch den gelb ist kein bisschen
leiser machen aber fast schon jetzt
ich wollte das einfach mal ausprobieren
wie das ist so mit live musik also wie
night music das anders aber wisst was
ich meine zu spielen weil ich ganz cool
finde ja im hintergrund läuft wie immer
weg center the [ __ ] das ist ergibt also
mein letzter gegner aufgegeben leute
nach dem 4 0 für mich jetzt ist mein
nächster da der heißt an fortschritt
nehmen so oder so gerade auch gestalter
wie geil wäre das bitte wenn ich die
komplette challenge einfach ohne einen
einzigen straff strich überstehen
wer eigentlich ganz nice
ich werde natürlich der fairness halber
trotzdem ganz normal spielen als ich
werde jetzt nicht nur auf meine eigene
torlinie stellen drauf spielen dass ich
keine tore kassiert wäre auch langweilig
anzuschauen
nein nein nein nein nein falsche
richtung falsche richtung
dumm gespielt alter okay sie das einst
so ok weiter geht's lasst es bei einem
top it also komplett unbescholten kommt
nicht mehr raus
wisst ihr das kann ich vielleicht ein
tor schießen ist ja auch ganz geil
einfach für mein eigenes ego ich das
ding ja noch ganz klein gewinnen wollen
ja sehr schön ausgleich wunderbar sie
sexy auf diese strich 90-60-90 sind die
maße dieses strich ist voll die es nicht
wissen
ola welle direkt geht die junge alles
durchkalkuliert wunderbar ilike dies
guck mal der musste die bahnstrecke
machen die seite kippte
margot dumm von mir okay sei ich habe
immer so scheiß ideen warum mache ich
das eigentlich mann
naja ich hoffe das ist wenigstens
hinterher zu hause ich schwöre du machst
ist kein turnier ein junge du jetzt ein
bisschen auf den sack langsam wie sagt
man angriff ist die beste verteidigung
also ab nach vorne sieht nicht gut aus
nein er geht aber nicht nee ja nicht weg
das ist verboten
ich spiele nicht ganz schlecht ganz
stellt die richtung ganz schlechte
richtung man dieses match ist gerade mal
zwei minuten alt
hier drüben über sieht so affig aus in
der festkelter ich verstehe nicht warum
mache ich so was
egal wir jetzt durch okay okay okay
sehr schön es geht nicht rein
wie gesagt ich will mein eigenes ego ist
ja noch gewinnen der war richtig
schlecht denn hätte man locker machen
können
rol inter das gut mit
ja ok gerettet kommt der geht rein
der fliegt schön aufs tor der geht rein
drei zu drei okay jetzt müssen aber noch
auf den spielen können ihr kind hewitt
sehr schön
rust einsammeln ihr klassiker ganz
wichtig ist so linien kämpfer guckt euch
das an wie ich solche menschen hatte ok
warum sage ich dass die menschen hast
dich machst mach ich selbst ja ich mache
glaube ich nicht selbst oder oder doch
ja bring ich auf dem kasten
ja mist kurz drehen
gefällt mir gar nicht was der macht hier
ja ok safe sehr schön und wieder ein
schlenker driften ganz wichtig ja indem
ich mit o2 darüber gezogen
eine minute 28 noch ich will das ding
auf jeden fall gewinnen
ja ja so als würde ich schon übertrieben
trick shop machen so ein mega seitlichen
ob wird zum verhängnis
er hatte genug druck ja jetzt noch den
fuß mit der mitte nein nein was mach ich
dich um drehte im juni gibt gas gibt gas
gibt gas gibt gas woher kommt einfach so
perfekt er geht nicht rein
jawohl
er wollte und jetzt noch mal hier
holst du eh nicht egal wer ihn aus
bekommen jetzt verpiss dich mal hier
sagt
der könnte aufs tor gehen aber da ist er
da nein nein nein nein nein nein
wo heute gefassten und jetzt der ersten
nachschuss nachschuss nein nach
erfassten es gibt sich rausholen mit
raus damit raus damit
jawohl sowohl für den ball
ok jetzt machen noch zehn sekunden noch
entscheidendes tor neuer bitte ja hier
ein die reihen geht doch einfach rein
na geht doch rein junge nachspielzeit
junge das war die gelegenheit so
schlecht stand ich doch gar nicht zum
schluss wie sie gehen nicht rein
oh ja alles so ok das war draußen
einsammeln woher verpassten ball sehr
schön hier liegt nicht schlecht der
liegt nicht schlecht geht er rein geht
er rein geht er rein sagt junge
wunderbar distimo krankhaft er ist immer
perfekt leute ihr habt das first try ich
habe drei gegentore kassierte man sieht
123 das was im heutigen video sich das
gefallen hat gerne leichter lassen oder
auch einen flaschen deckel bitte nur in
blau bis ins nächste video wieder haut
rein macht's gut
gbp und dju